the strategies that that that Dr fauci
had espoused at the time had failed and
it had caused tremendous damage to the
poor the children the working class at
the time in the summer of 2020 there
were estimates that a hundred million
people would be thrown into poverty
worldwide because of the economic
dislocation caused by Dr fauci's
lockdowns 130 million people according
to the world food program in the U.N
were going to be we're we're at risk of
dire food insecurity meaning starvation
the lockdowns were tremendously damaging
the health of the of the world and Dr
fauci uh rather than trying to Grapple
with the actual critique we had uh
essentially organized a propaganda
campaign